yeah speaking of sludge we haven't done
a relationship advice in a while and yes
what just fits perfectly oh it's great
don't you read the title of this cuz my
OBS just crashed so I'll fix that well
how'd you read this yeah let me pull it
up real quick we really haven't done one
of these in a long time
by the way you want to read this yes
okay so we haven't we haven't done one
of these in a long time and so we're
back with relationship advice mm-hmm
this one the title is my GF has skid
marks in her underwear and I don't know
how to bring it up without embarrassing
slash shaming her and I'll let you do
you want to do the honors uh
i-26 male I've been dating my 24 female
girlfriend for about seven months now
we've been quarantined together and
technically been together 24/7 for the
last ten weeks or so I sometimes do
laundry and I've noticed like that
sometimes some of her underwear has
poopy skid marks this is a 26 year old
man saying poopy skid marks come on bruh
shitty skid marks yeah just a skid mark
or just there's no way to say that
maturely but morally maturely you know
little little paintbrush pattern my
girlfriend has marker smear fecal marks
yeah
panty panties poorly rated fecal skid
all right our first notice got a little
turd turd marks oh man I was gonna make
a really bad Formula one joke because
you know Formula One has three rated
tires soft medium and hard you guys skid
marks in her underwear soft rated just
you know as opposed to a hard smear you
know yeah
got it hard smeared she's got a turd
smears yeah I don't know how to say this
for lack of a better word she has turd
smears in her panties got sludge sludge
things she got sludge stand there you go
sludge things sorry for everyone trying
to eat right now I first noticed a few
weeks ago when we were at a friend's
lake house and I was drunk and I noticed
her underwear on the floor I jokingly
point out to her babe what's that she's
obviously very embarrassed but we kind
of let it go anyway I did a load this
week sounds like she did a load this
week too and like three of her underwear
had them so now I'm wondering if this is
a real issue to address she's well put
together in grad school very smart and
pretty and it's very good hygiene
otherwise but I'm trying figure out how
to bring this up without making her feel
bad about herself bro what if this is
just blood and this dude has no idea how
a period works there's a stain in her
underwear and I think it's doodoo she's
like I have a heavy flow dick kind of
seems like she might be pooping out of
her vagina I'm concerned my girlfriend
poops out of two holes I've noticed
weird brown stains in the front of her
underwear and I didn't think that was
possible
that's honestly it also he kind of seems
like that might be the issue I wonder
what if any of the comments say that
yeah we're never gonna know cuz I don't
know what website this came from so yeah
I have no idea what is this text are /
no idea it's weird I am asking for help
and advice I don't want to change her or
seem controlling she's amazing and
usually very clean while it's def gross
I love her and this is not a
deal-breaker but I do want to try and
help her in this regard like he thinks
it might be a medical issue yeah
I don't know he may stop asking her to
wear butt plugs and you know it'll some
I'm scared you might have chronic turd
itis baby I'm worried you have chronic
to smear I'm where you have to smear
blood slip panty sludge itis I'm worried
you might have that panty sludge itis
sounds legit
I'm babe I'm concerned you have the the
turd piece nice tortora chronic turd
area chronic front tire right diorite as
I write is there you go this morning I
woke up my wife took off her no we're
not fine she got diorite Asst
mid-thirties woman in a pharmaceutical
commercial I take tramadol for my
chronic front [ __ ] dire itis tramadol
sister the first medical sounding thing
I take percocets for my aweful diarrhea
I take tram it also comes out the back
instead of the front my awful Fupa dire
itis
so funny like mom my stomach hurts
Oh maybe should have some percocet oh
your stomach hurts honey here here's a
purty it's just me doing heroin cram it
all for my kids just knocked out for
like eight hours first area our friend
comes over what's wrong with Billy he
had a tummy ache so I gave him percocet
pass that would [ __ ] diarrhea all
over the place I think it helped you
know it just takes time you have to let
it work itself off it makes it all come
out then you'll clean it up it's fine
you